it's time for roses and Rose Bay with
Corinne babe you are here you guys we
have never had a guest for roses and
Rose a before Corinne olimpio sis here
round of applause from everyone we have
a huge studio audience for it
you guys we always do is a but Corinne
loves champagne so we have Rose a
champagne can you do the honors
absolutely it's my favorite thing to do
everybody knows what an exciting start
our first guest ever for roses and roses
so we are going to get to know re today
just some kid just right now yeah for
sure
it's been a little surreal sorry we
don't know we don't know who he is
cheers babe never feeling really
emphatic about something I like to hit a
little high note like I'll drink and it
feels really good I do that all the time
like I'll just be sitting in my house
with like oh I like the people around
like you know what you just have to let
it out
yeah I gotta let it out I'm cheers to
starting it off okay yes in those bad
days like I'm not sure if I want to stay
were you surprised that Peter wasn't the
bachelor
I was surprised um I mean it was going
around and he was gonna be the bachelor
and that's not it it was a whole thing
and then he just wasn't if Peter had
been the bachelor would you have come I
think I would have I think I would have
we maybe I wouldn't have I don't know
cuz I've liked Rachel like the whole
thing I'm like I love her so much
what are your thoughts on re first
impression from like when you saw him
and heard the
I was just like okay that's cool like
they're going back to their roots kind
of maybe it's not gonna be like so
focused on like girls like about social
media and like popularity maybe it's
gonna be more of kind of like really
really like trying to find love really
old school we are talking about 2012
where were you in 2012 I didn't know
what I was doing
how old was I I mean I was I don't know
time here was are his package in 2012
and listen package my father's order but
I'm a race car driver can't even
understand them no we get it
I've traveled oh wow I long married in
full bodysuit whoa whoa having a brain
fart
are you I'm having a brain fart so I
just thought he was like gonna be more
old soul kind of thing cause like he has
the gray hair training that he like
talks like a Nick 99% sure all right
interesting like a Nick vile
hi I'm current how did you do when they
had you film the pensive stares comes
inflation is that what they say yeah
look like what advice do they give you
contemplate think about what you're
doing here think about what's going on
they filmed this season is the only time
they've ever filmed it they filmed it in
Charlotte because she could be near her
daughter so this is like not the
bachelor mansion oh no way I didn't know
this I didn't watch her season
okay go coca you're finally how many
candles are there for real when you're
there is it is it hot it's hot and there
are definitely like 35 minutes okay so I
don't know who's young she was a nice to
me on Twitter and that's all I know I
don't know
block that down knock it out is that how
you deal with that just lock it out like
you don't even know me Brown no
literally don't know yes what was going
through your mind on limo night like
were you nervous are you feeling nervous
is not the word wow it's so good so good
she's stunning oh my god this gives me
like anxiety why's that
oh my god I just bring you right back to
like when I was in limo like it's just
strange feeling your night is just
getting started
next limo pulling into the driveway
getting a limo it's like wow like I it's
like for someone like starting a brand
new step in their life it's emotional
I'm emotionally exhausted just hearing
you say sorry I don't know what I'm
saying but like you know it's emotion
fellow batch fam you know y'all not
remember who was in the limo with you
crazy limo Vanessa Raven and Taylor like
won a limo right what a limo
come on of course they made me get out
first honestly I was like look why are
they making me go first
I like didn't know where to go when I
got into limo I was like walking around
they're all like
I'm a hugger is that okay awesome family
meeting Doug Doug like what's weird is
like you know I don't know they seem you
do you think what's your type do you
have a type like I know an everyday by
the long title okay I don't like blonds
Emily needs Jeff home so this guy oh I
don't like Jeff home why not cuz I heard
really bad things about him what have
you heard
he just doesn't treat them incorrectly
yeah okay so Doug's great then Emily
meet sorry it's so weird it's like it's
like like you don't know how lucky you
are until you're in that positions like
bringing me right back that place I'm
like wow what one piece of advice would
you tell any of them be yourself
yourself take every moment and don't be
nervous about it because you're gonna be
sorry if you were nervous about it what
is that oh oh oh no oh no oh oh no she
did a handshake this is like did Nick
hug you did he hug everyone I remember
Nick just gave me like I don't have any
tokens on me I know if Nick was like
that person all the time the person the
person when I got a limo I wish he was
that person all the time I feel like
throughout the season he just totally
changed it was like he did a 360 I
remember the time I noticed it too I I
remember we have this amazing connection
and like even when the cameras weren't
rolling he'd come over and he's like
none to me and like you sorry did I hurt
you no yeah do you like the cutest
things and I just remember when he just
changed completely I went up to him um
camera's not rolling there was like I'm
just gonna give you a hug before the
night like ends like whatever
which is something we normally did and
he was just like okay well I'm gonna go
give out this rose now and I was like
woah honestly I still to this day I'm
shocked that I got sent home after that
hometown date Shh I mean you I thought
he made a huge mistake
[Music]
you had I would say literally the best
limo exit ever I loved your speech at
the time it was before I'd ever even
gotten to interview I loved your speech
why can't I just have a normal
relationship
you were so about I am owning Who I am
and I'm moving forward to get what I
deserve I'm trying to show my men how
much I worship them and they love that
do you feel good about how you left
yourself it's so funny because ever so
upset and that's actually how I felt
like I wasn't even thinking that they
were gonna hear any of that and I
remember I wear the hottest outfit ya
know it's like there's no way I'm going
home tonight
and then and everyone was like L know
[Applause]
what about the bouncy house did you ask
for that yeah I did that was all me
drink to people who aren't boring give
me a high one give me a high one yes how
are you in Taylor oh no no oh yeah it's
a no you don't want to have your wedding
with your small little diamond room
you're fine I think me and Ari are gonna
wind up together and I wonder who he
picks are you attracted to if he's you
why you know I just I'm struggling with
the fact that I was so attracted to
Peter Peter Peter and there's not a bad
time you are working on a sunglasses
line yeah I this sunglasses I work to
create a special frame with them profits
go to child help dot org helping
children I'm so excited
helping the children's your self into
children of course yeah helping always
help if you can team corn shop calm yes
my merch my sunglasses that's really
good the children
re and last question for you re we've
watched him a little bit today how would
you describe him in a few words after
just the brief moment so you seen cute
confident self controlled do we like
self-control I don't know we'll see babe
here's to you thanks for being here you
for having me iced roses and love Z but
you guys make sure to LIKE ET on
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube and
have to team corn shop.com where you can
get all of this woman's fabulous
merchandise and follow her on social
media she's amazing and so excited to
see you on our TV screens again
hopefully soon hopefully soon bye bye
[Applause]
okay your gatherin get yours together
drink up for getting your together mmm I
love when we ever together I never do